welcome to the stoah the stoah is a
digital campfire where equal hear and
dialogue about what matters most at the
night's edge what's happening now
[Music]
so check-ins yeah I'm excited just sort
of like a calm excitement so welcome to
the stoah I'm Peter Lindbergh Stewart of
the stoah stoah is a place for us to go
here and dialogue about what matters
most at the knife's edge of this moment
and today we are lucky to have my buddy
Jonathan pujo join us at the stoma
jonathan is a professional artist writer
and public speaker who gives workshops
and conferences all around North America
and he carves Eastern Orthodox icons and
other traditional Christian images and
his excellent YouTube series called the
symbolic world that explores symbols and
images that are floating around in our
culture so today Jonathan's going to
talk about the ecstasy of 20/20 and he's
gonna share his kind of thoughts about
what's happening all the craziness
that's happening in the world and then
we're gonna have a discussion so anytime
Jonathan's talking if you have a
question that comes along I've just
write in the chat box and when we get to
the Q&A portion I will call on you and
you can answer your ask your question to
Jonathan and if you want me to read it
on your behalf because this is will be
on YouTube just indicate that in the
chat and then I will do so so that being
said I will unmute you Jonathan and hand
it over to you all right it's nice to
meet everybody I'm happy to be for the
first time on the stove I've been
hearing a lot of great things and you
know I've been following Peter kind of
from afar I think I was on his podcast
awhile ago and obviously read some I was
writing as I'm sure most of you have
very very astute person so I'm happy to
kind of be in this little inner clique
that he's developed to talk about
meaning and problems with meaning and
just the madness of the situation and so
as everybody as everybody probably saw
yesterday well you two days ago actually
two days ago on the 4th of July Kanye
West announced that he was going to run
for president of the United States
and it's just very interesting because
in January I think I was in January
early 2020 I went or I late 2019 I
forget when Konya put out his album I
actually started talking about Kanye
West quite a bit I did three videos on
him and it was actually the strange
moment where that there was a Newsweek
article written about my take on Kanye
West for some reason and it just plays
in everything nicely plays into what is
happening and my contention for the past
few years is that we are in we're at the
end of something you know you can see it
how big as big as you want to see it you
know whether it's the end of Western
civilization whether it's the end of one
cycle of Western civilization the end of
the Enlightenment the end I don't know
when a for sure there's some there are
many images which are showing us that
we're at the end of something and the
the breakdown in meaning the breakdown
in unity the and then also the
inversions the fact that things keep
flipping on one side and the other is a
sign that we are you know can you
imagine like a wheel that's turning and
as it turns if you can imagine the wheel
gets bigger and bigger and bigger or you
know the bigger it gets at some point
the wheel is gonna start to wobble and
is going to start to to lose its
coherence and that seems to be the point
where we're in and in the ancient the
ancients had a vision of the world every
culture had the same vision that where
they saw themselves as that's a center
or an identity of some kind
and then as you moved out from that
identity you had progressively stranger
and stranger people obviously more
people who were more appeared stranger
to you because they were more different
from you and then as you moved out and
out you reach the monsters which were
you know these things that didn't you
how you didn't have name names for the
things that appeared to you as an
unknown and then the further you went
and you reached the edge of the world
where you would see what appear to you
as upside down behavior the Greeks of
course had the the Amazons were the
ultimate example for the Greeks because
the Greeks were extremely
let's say male-dominated and so they had
this image of something at the edge of
the world described at the edge of the
world was the opposite of them and which
was female dominated female the the
women were warriors and the men were
barely around or barely important in
that society and so that that that type
of inversion can play put many roles
like it doesn't necessarily have to take
on one form it can take on many forms
but it it has its image in the the
vision of the world like this kind of
cosmic vision but it also appears in our
society as well in terms of a fringe
element of our society and I've used the
carnival as the ultimate example where
the carnival aesthetic seems to embody
mostly this fringe you know the the idea
of turning faster and faster the notion
of the freakshow that note all these
images of the carnival the clown the the
acrobatics the whole idea of turning and
turning and turning and so I the fact
that things are so unstable is that's
when we're starting to see these these
elements come into play now the problem
with the the breakdown is that there are
also movements to try to clamp down and
those two end up happening at the same
time and the danger that we that we fall
into is to want to take one side or the
other we seem to think that we need to
decide which side were on either we're
on the side of those who want to break
down the world or on the side of those
who want to clamp things down and kind
of hold on for dear life you know and
and create extreme versions of identity
and extreme versions of of holding in
and so we're gonna see that it's gonna
it's gonna get worse I just want to warn
you it's gonna get a lot worse but we've
started to see this kind of playing out
and 2020 so when I made that video was
when I made that video about Kanye West
in 2019 or early 2020 I told everybody I
said hold hold on for 2020 because it's
gonna be crazy but I have to admit that
I didn't expect so much to be happening
in so little time but at the same time
I'm not completely surprised and so what
we're seeing is we're seeing this test
of identity now people don't realize how
a disease or how the pandemic was a test
of identity or was a question of
identity I think maybe people can now
start to perceive it as they might have
perceived how people's let's say even
their alignment in terms of what they
would do for the pandemic ended up being
more on political lines rather than
anything else you know because the facts
are so fluid and they keep coming at it
from all these directions people ended
up taking taking political lines for
medical in with medical and medical
veneer let's say but the reason why it's
such a question of identity is because
there's an analogy and it's a scary
analogy but there is an analogy between
the person and the the body politic
there's an analogy between a human being
and a society and so just like and and
you you can try to break that analogy
down but it you it were made to
experience that analogy and what ended
up happening with the pandemic was ended
up being a question of walls it ended up
being a question of where do you put the
walls and that was as we've been
discussing that you know you had Donald
Trump saying build the wall and then you
Justin Trudeau saying diversity is our
strength it's like these two opposites
like one is build a wall the other is no
identity
you know just identity no identity this
this insane type of rhetoric that we
could see coming up on both sides of the
political aisle
well the pandemic put that right into
your body and it made it it linked the
whole meaning crisis into our bodies and
so the question became where do we put
the wall how hard do we make the wall
and is the wall where is the value of
the wall right and so because you could
have said well do we close down borders
for countries do we close down borders
hierarchically in terms of we see
where the breakouts are and then we shut
down walls in different places or do we
shut down walls all the way down to the
individual and we separate everybody
from each other and so that is if you
want to understand a lot of the debate
that was happening that was part of the
large debate that was going on now the
one that ended up winning seems to have
been the one where we separate everybody
from each other and we create as little
as little fragmented bits as possible
and we shut down everything now shutting
down everything is is interesting
because the things we shut down are a
lot of the things that people use to
let's say to manifest their their
communal aspect you know obviously we
shut down meetings we shut down churches
we shut down stores we also shut down
sports sports is a huge deal and it's
bigger than a lot of people think
because the there is a certain type of
person which really needs to identify
which really need to identify to have an
enemy and to have some kind of fight and
sports is is actually a great way to
channel that so that you will actually
then you avoid conflict because you give
people the possibility of saying this is
my team I love my team those that other
team we're gonna beat them you know and
so it's a it's a it's a less dangerous
way of fun obviously you can get out of
control we can see that in in England
with the hooligans and stuff but it's
the less dangerous way to funnel
identity and conflict then let's say a
social conflict but we took that away we
took that away from everybody and so
everybody was just in their home
separated from each other completely
apart and then something happened now it
could have been other things but the
thing that happened made sense in terms
of the obviously the political narrative
that has been that has been prevalent in
universities that have been prevalent
in in society in general this idea of a
kind of neutral
kind of a kind of rule of the margin you
could say and so we identified someone
we watched him get murdered and that's
really when's the last time you watched
someone actually get murdered we don't
watch people get murdered
we swatch it on TV we watch movies but
most of the time those images are taken
away from us like most of the time we're
not permitted by media or whatever and
for some good reason to watch someone be
killed but for some reason this this
video became extremely available for
everybody to watch a man be murdered
during eight minutes and then then there
was a catharsis explosion because what
happened in that murder what happened in
that murder is exactly a catharsis it's
exactly a classical catharsis because
what we were asked to do especially the
white people like especially the the
especially the Westerners were asked to
identify with the victim like obviously
you want to identify with the victim
because you you see this man suffer and
you're like I this is unbearable
I can't stand watching someone be
tortured to death and it's driving you
crazy but then you're also asked to
identify with the killer and you're
supposed to do that at the same time
you're supposed to both identify with
the person who's murdered and identify
with the killer and the the I'll give
you an example of another place where
that happens it's in the story of Christ
that's another place where that happens
where you're supposed to both identify
with Christ being killed but you're also
supposed to identify with those who
killed Christ and so it was exactly a
catharsis and it led to a a ecstatic
explosion it led to an ecstasy and then
people rushed into the streets to
protest to commune to commune in the
name of this cathartic moment to commune
in the shadow of this
and all the images we saw the chanting
the kneeling the the there were some
crazier images in that there people
being whipped
there were people washing the feet of
others there were all these religious
expressions of of communion in the name
of this cathartic moment and in the name
of of inclusivity you could say I don't
know how to name the value you could
call it inclusivity something like that
and there and then there was
scapegoating it's just inevitable
there was scapegoating in the sent and
it's weird scapegoating because if you
look at how the event played through
like if you're trying to stay cool it
was hard to stay cool during that time
but if you looked at how the event
played out you could see that everybody
agreed that this was horrible everybody
I don't think I ever I don't think I saw
anybody who thought it was not horrible
I mean I saw I saw that the man was
arrested that the other people were put
on I think they might have been arrested
- I don't even know but I know they were
for sure fired and then everybody
denounced it every conservative every
liberal every politician at every level
denounced it then every corporation
denounced it I received emails from
every single corporation that exists you
know denouncing what happened and but
for somehow some reason there was still
this idea that we all of these people
everybody basically who hated what to
see this happen were the resistance and
we're that we're that we're the
resistance to the evil system and we
need to find those that are responsible
for the evil system and because they're
the system then we can purge them and
we're totally justified in purging them
because we are the victims and if we're
the victims and the culprit then even
better reason to now find those who are
more responsible than us and purge them
from the system and so it was it was
just a classical scapegoating and it was
a weird scapegoating - because it was
kind of like it was like it's always
like this these weird
these like shadowy figures that we never
hear names of it's like this evil system
with like evil white supremacists that
are managing it but it's like who are
these people I mean I guess Donald Trump
is one of the people who is kind of seen
as the the one to two point you but in
general he was like a very much a kind
of weird scapegoating and so it really
did lead to a pseudo religious event and
I and and one of and the final marker of
the pseudo religious event is the human
sacrifice the human sacrifice is the
clincher which makes it a religious
event so and you have to you have to see
the human sacrifice within the narrative
of the people who are operating the
sacrifice so it's not even about being
objective or whatever or the so certain
group of people or as people on a
certain side or people in this certain
side of the political aisle said that
you cannot go outside you're not allowed
to commune you're not allowed to get
together with others you're not allowed
to to meet if you do that you are
killing your grandmother
you are killing people if you come
together and then they said you should
come together not because you're not
killing people but because we are
subjecting this to a higher value this
is a higher value protesting racism is
higher it is the ultimate value under
which we are ready to sacrifice all
other values underneath it and we are
also willing to sacrifice people and of
course it's worth it conscious no one
said we're doing human sacrifice but the
pattern of human sacrifice was exactly
being played out in their own narrative
and so that is why everything looks so
weird and so religious because it it
played it followed a very religious
pattern now of course it's it's a
frightening it's a little frightening in
terms of pattern because it's not clear
how it's going
to play out it's not clear how the
catharsis is completely resolved I'm not
sure how it's resolved in the story in
the story of Christ there is a capacity
for resolution right there's a capacity
for forgiveness there's a capacity to
come into full communion with each other
I don't know if in this religious moment
there's really a capacity for absolution
if there is I haven't seen it yet like I
haven't seen the capacity for absolution
and so it is a little frightening to
watch this happen and so it's gonna
continue it's gonna continue because it
this year is way for it's far from being
over there's still an election and now
you have this fool character Kanye West
who really does play the role of a of a
fool who is now tossed in the game so
what he so he's the real trump card way
more than Donald Trump he is way more a
trump card than Trump and so and then
and it's funny because people are saying
he's there just to steal the votes from
Biden but I don't know he might be there
to steal the votes from Trump because he
is he who knows because people he is
presenting himself as like a
conservative Christian who's married to
Kim Kardashian I just want you guys to
realize how insane the situation is and
so he's he's he's flying under the
banner of a conservative Christian but
obviously you know I don't know he's
doing an album with dr. Dre and he is
and he's hanging out with Kim car - and
he's married to Kim Kardashian and so
who knows whose votes he's gonna take I
don't know but for sure like there's
gonna be some more madness in this year
coming along so I wish I could offer
solutions to what we're seeing but right
now a basic like and just look and and
watch with my jaw like just fall in and
and hope for the best
cool ready for some yes sure yeah
so we already had some questions in the
chatbox just throw your questions for
Jonathan I'm gonna warm him up with a
few so if you should recall when this
whole cool good thing came online
there was this meme that said the virus
broke woke and it's sort of like it was
quiet you know the the woke stuff for a
bit and then just boom crashed online is
like whoa broke the virus and it was
almost felt like the virus will have a
superordinate goal that we could kind of
like instrument fly like you know rally
behind together but then didn't happen
and I really liked your frame with the
higher-value thing and it seems like
you're you're kind of like what is it
inclusion but it seems like anti racism
is this just one value and so is that
are we rolling behind right now what's
the media and that's not just anti
racism it's very important to realize
that black lives matter and black lives
matter very quickly put on a very very
large black trans live matters black
lives matter the organization is not
just about black lives matter it is
about it is about the diversity equity
inclusion that's what it is and that's
why they made they hurried up to put out
a a black trans live matter because they
wanted to signal that it is about
inclusion and it is not just about not
just about racism there's that there's a
there's a bigger aspect to this thing
that is not just it's not only captured
by racism mm-hmm so what I was gonna say
is it is it a positive value like
inclusion or is it like a negative value
like you know not this like anti racism
or something and you think it's more of
a inclusion positive value that's that's
being gestured in this ecstasy
well it's inclusion inclusion is not a
positive value necessarily it can be
positive and it can be negative and it's
like every it's like everything
everything in excess is is dangerous and
so absolute inclusion not one of us one
of the things that I've been trying to
explain or hope people understand is the
role of the margin and what marginality
is
and it's let's say the power of the
margin the function of the map margin
and the dangers of the margin now one of
the dangers with the inclusivity
proposition that is being presented is
that we want to include everything
equally in an equal measure and so what
we want is we want the exception to be
equal to the rule and that doesn't work
that type of inclusion will break the
system it'll break everything because in
order to in order to take something
marginal and try to make it equal to the
rule the only way to do it is to flip to
make it upside down is to emphasize the
margin is to make the margin the rule
it's the only way to do it because
naturally it just it just doesn't it's
there are things in the world which are
just naturally marginal that are just
that are just freaky that are just
things that happen once in a while that
are that are and and they have a power
which is useful in the world like
they're they're useful for a society
that we have these that we have the
freak shows that we have the the things
that are that are strange on the on the
edges but if you try to make so here
okay so let me phrase it in a way let me
phrase it in a way that is that is easy
to understand but is scary in its
implications and so you have a country
right and this country has a limit right
and then on the outside of that country
then you have everything that is strange
all the strangers all the foreigners now
they're innumerable and they have they
have multiple identities there they have
an indefinite amount of identities
because the outside is always bigger
than the inside and so what happens when
you want to make the stranger more
important than that which is inside
or if you want the stranger to be
equally included on the inside as the
inside then you it things get loopy very
fast because you end up having you'd end
up hat because the then one who's inside
has a natural has a natural advantage on
the inside because they're on the inside
they're part of the group the part of
the identity doesn't matter which which
type could be a knitting club or it
could be a soccer club or it could be a
country or a sadly it can also be things
like a race or things like a religion it
can be all kinds of things now if you
want now to include everything you have
to do it in a way too you have to
prioritize that which is outside because
that which is an aside inside naturally
has advantage so you end up prioritizing
that which is outside and then things
get crazy loopy things start because
then what is this thing it's all gonna
fall apart it's an it's inevitably gonna
fall apart
I always kind of joke like if you have a
knitting group and then and then there's
like you know I don't know like Betty
has a friend in her knitting group who
comes to the knitting group but she
doesn't really knit right she's just
there to hang out or maybe to talk to
the others cuz she likes people and
that's totally fine but then what if you
you want her to be equal to all the
other members of the knitting group it's
gonna get really complicated cuz then
she said well I don't want to knit I
want to do something else like I want to
play play bowling or something so it's
like okay well once in a while we'll
have a bowling event because we want to
include you in the group but then at
some point it's gonna start to break
down
you know anyways that that's that's the
problem of the of the that can be that's
the danger of equal inclusion it just
you just can't just can't work in terms
of a system hmm so we're gonna pivot to
some questions a lot of good questions
popping up but ask one more this Konya
have a chance to win yeah I can't I
don't say my goodness there anything's
possible right now anything is possible
I don't know what I to be honest for all
my love of Kanye West like I've followed
Kanye West
since 2000 since his first album 2004 I
think and I love his music and I think
he's a fascinating person but I hope he
doesn't win but anything's possible at
this point Kim Kardashian First Lady the
stores gonna wait to see who it endorses
for 2020 so this whole tight it might be
easy the rain you had a question as
related to Kanye actually maybe we can
double click on that one yeah well I'd
be curious maybe others are more aware
than I am I I don't spend a lot of time
on social media I haven't followed Kanye
I just hear indirectly about him I also
didn't watch your videos so if there is
other interest in the group I was just
curious if you wanted to summarize any
of your analysis and just say anything
else about what role Kanye's playing and
everything that's happening so so my so
my contention in general about the fool
is that the fool is the one who's who
turns things you know so the image of
the clown is perfect he's on the ball
he's rolling a ball he's juggling and so
the fool is the one who turns things and
so when when things are going well with
the fool tee it tends to do is to turn
things upside down right to show the
upside down to something so the king is
all pompous and is is is extremely proud
of himself and so the king will lift up
the his skirt and will point to the
thing that's hidden right he'll point to
the to the to the hidden things which
are in the shadows let's say and so the
clown is always kind of turning things
right and he's emphasizing excess
caricature all of that now the problem
is that when the world is upside down
then what's the role of the clown when
everything is already topsy-turvy what
does the clown do well the clown keeps
turning the clown will turn things and
so what I've been trying to point out is
that when the world is is upside down
watch the fools because the fools are
the ones who are actually going to turn
things right-side up who are going to
turn things back towards order and so I
saw that
ready in Kanye a long time ago in 2004
he did this song called Jesus walks
which was a really strange song because
it's a song about about street life and
hustling and all these things but then
he's he he talks about how jesus walks
with the lowest basically so he's saying
you know he's talking about he needs to
go do a drug deal and he's gonna leave
his mom to do a drug deal and he says I
hope that Jesus walks with me and so
he's connecting like the highest thing
with the lowest okay um so I was really
keen watching him since then and now he
he basically became like a conservative
Christian he had a conversion experience
and he's now he's all like pro family
pro he's he's all about he's become
super conservative and he's not the
first one for who that happens I've been
watching certain characters in in in the
past few years one of the examples I
give is Gavin McGinnis who obviously
he's been really really kind of thrown
around in the media but as a character
he was interesting because he found
advice news and he was he was a he was a
punk he was a punk pervert all this
stuff and all of us at some point it's
like the whole world became like him
what does a punk do in the whole world
is punk rock and so he actually he's
like I can't stand this and then he
started to point back to the to the to
normalcy got married had kids became a
Knights of Columbus you know started
wearing buttoned up shirts and it's like
he was just it's like the when when the
the world is exceptional the exceptional
points back to the rule it happens very
naturally and so Kanye I think that
that's what Kanye is doing so if you
look at his tweet it's crazy because he
says we need I forget the exact wording
but it's like we need to follow God and
to find our unifying principle or
whatever and that's why I'm running for
president of the United States
that's Kanye West who's writing that
like you know the guy the guy who would
dress up in a big teddy bear suit that
guy that guy is saying we need to go
back to God and find our unified prints
of
and so that's what I mean when I talk
about the fool kind of watching the fool
at the end because the fool is the one
who's going to bring back to bring back
order
I mean whether you agree with the order
he brings back or not the finding the
point to watch it as a phenomena is to
just see it happen like Kanye West is
more conservative than Donald Trump
that's how weird this world is help I
understand a little bit what I was
talking about Jeff any follow-up
questions ring no thank you
Jacob you had a question it's my mic
working yeah hi Jonathan so my question
is to do with what what is the
relationship between the the current
movement and the Christian substrate in
the kind of unconscious layer and just
one more piece I want to attack on to
this is if we're kind of stepping back
to like the mid 19th century around like
Nietzsche and if this movement has kind
of Marxist foundations and what's the
relationship between the Marxist
foundations and Christianity as well
with Marxism kind of coming out of the
same substrate so any what I would I've
tried to point to is that the modern
world is basically the breakdown of
Christianity and so I mean it's there
historically that's what it is you know
it's the the rise of scientific atheism
there are the rise of just a basic
cultural atheism you could say or
secularism and so what happens in that
what happens in that breakdown of
Christianity is that Christianity starts
to pull apart and so certain aspects of
Christianity start to manifest disorder
in a disordered manner and so there is
an aspect of Christianity which is an
mentioned to the little one right
attention to the poor and a desire for a
form of I would say it that way I would
say attention to the poor attention to
the margin-right Christ goes out finds
the lost sheep yeah there's all these
images in Christian Christianity
obviously just the Beatitudes are a lot
about that and so that value in itself
is good but it's it's dangerous if it's
just taking taken on its own it's very
dangerous and that's what I think one of
the aspects of Marxism is it's that it's
it's a it's it's a desire for what we
know it's like it's a utopian desire
it's a desire for a certain aspect of
utopia and their their vision of utopia
is a kind of equality utopia and then
there are other utopias and we saw them
in the 20th century which are
hierarchical utopias and so those two
are gonna are that those two are what
led to World War two a hierarchical
utopia and an ending in egalitarian
utopia and we're gonna see it happen
again because we never dealt with it and
it's the same movements it's just
hilarious it's not funny but it's
hilarious because you you want to you go
you go online and look for an T for
images from the 1920s in Germany to be
surprised that that's one of the one of
the things that led to the to to where
Germany ended up was the very same
questions that we're dealing with now
and people are really struggling because
there's a desire for a secular utopia
and so the idea in the religious context
is that if the highest thing is the
highest thing so I say it's like I say
the highest thing is the infinite or the
highest thing is being or the highest
thing is love right being loved infinite
then it's not a
are you in terms of morality I did
something beyond the value in terms of
morality morality will flow out of it
but but it's not an absolute it's not
it's not a value and so what we're
seeing now is exactly that it's and so
that there is definitely the BLM is
definitely Marxist like the founders are
Marxists their desires are extremely
Marxist in their formulations and
they're using I don't know how conscious
it is but they're definitely used using
kind of religious imagery to get people
on board and to get people excited about
about their project and so I don't but
there is no there is no happy ending to
this to that story like this there is no
happy ending to what - what DLM is
asking for it can't end well
so relatedly Amy you had a question yeah
thunderstorm here I hope you hear me yes
I got a question about the kind of I
would have been noticing about this kind
of there's a relationship I see between
text and image in the pseudo religious
moment and I was wondering and that
there's a schedule calls for iconoclasm
to destroy images in the form statues
and also to worship certain new text
white fragility like the best-selling
focus in the United States right now so
I wonder if you have any thoughts about
that yeah well one of it when I talk
about the end of something one of the
images of the end is the is iconoclasm
that is when something breaks down you
you want to break down the memory of it
because you'd the image I often give is
if you if you buy a house and you when
you move into the house you find that
people have left pictures of their
family there the first thing you're
going to do is you're going to remove
the pictures of the people's family so
that you can settle in now that has
normal implications but it also has very
our implications if you play it out in
terms of social social questions now one
of the things that happening now it's
not that we're it's not like a switch of
house but it's actually people who are
trying to break down the identity of the
family break down the identity of those
that have held the house until now and
so when you see iconoclasm it's that
it's definitely a it's a transition it's
it's a transition towards other statues
it's a transition for you to put then
other ideals up there for people to to
venerate so and some of the stuff that
they're pulling down maybe should be
pull down it's possible like there's
some you know there's there's some dark
stuff in the us-south maybe I don't know
you know it's not I'm not it's not it's
not my thing
I'm Canadian I'm french-canadian I have
other markers you know there are people
there are like there are people here
there's Kuna been here in Canada and
there are statues of him and there are
some dark aspects to his story but to be
honest I don't think it would be a good
idea to pull down his statue because he
did found you know large swaths of the
North here but there are dark aspects
and so one of the way that I framed it
too is the the idea of hiding the
nakedness of your father and so in the
world of all identities are no identity
is perfect all identities are broken
because they're not they're not let's
say they're not God right and so all
identities have a broken is to them and
so in order in order for them to hold
together one of the things you have to
do is you have to hide their nakedness
and I take that from the story in the
Bible where Noah the father the new
father right so there's a flood
everything's destroyed now there's no
way he's gonna be the father of
everybody else right the whole world is
going to be is gonna be related to Noah
and then he gets drunk and he passes out
naked in his tent and one of his sons
sees him naked and makes fun of him
because he's naked and then he's cursed
because of that now his other sons go in
and they hide his nakedness they cover
his nakedness okay so you have to
understand it as in order to preserve an
identity you have to
to a certain extent hide the nakedness
of your father the the problem is always
knowing when is it too much like when
are you hiding too much but everybody
does it right
imagine you have a basketball team and
your star player has some negative
aspects to them well you don't want to
be publicly telling everybody about the
bad habits of your star basketball
player because you won't you don't want
your basketball team to be dismantled
and you don't want to lose and it's the
same for any team any church any school
any group and so we need to hide the
nakedness of our father but at some
point and so at some point you have to
stop if it's too much right because we
saw too much of it like all the priests
abusing children and then people
covering up for them all the coaches and
using children all that kind of stuff is
when you do it too much now the problem
is that if you hide the nakedness of
your father it's still there the scandal
is hidden but it's still there and at
some point at in the end it's going to
appear it's going to show itself the
system is going to play itself out the
weakness of the system that you hid at
the beginning is going to be its
downfall at the end and it's going to be
what the aunt that your enemies used to
destroy and it's just inevitable it's
just gonna happen that way and so
America has sins in its origin it has
hidden sins and the hidden sin is that
that which they declared which is
equality fraternity freedom in their
founding they hid a sin which is that it
wasn't true for everything that they
infants in saying that they also hid
their own sins and now they're coming
out and they have been coming out but
it's it's hard it's hard to avoid that
happening at some point now I don't know
when it's supposed to happen but it's a
hard for that to not to not happen but
it and we have to be careful not to
point fingers because this what I'm
telling you is true of every system and
it's true of every family and it's true
of every any organization has hidden
sins
it's just part of a system okay so we
have a lot of questions we're gonna get
all of them but we've got Dominic you
got a question Thanks hi Jonathan
hey can you point us the stories in
anticipation of the inclusion or
exclusion of those who don't choose the
side of either the breakdown on the
clampdown if I can find those that don't
choose either/or it usually ends up in
the stories usually don't look they
don't look very pretty they don't end up
in a so okay I'll give you I'll give you
an example where both sides are shown
next to each other okay so it's in the
story of Exodus in the story of Exodus
the Israelites leave Egypt and when they
leave Egypt they gather all the rabble
with them so it's basically you can
imagine that as these slight as these
Israelite slaves are being freed and are
leaving Israel a bunch of people are
like well I'm getting it on this and so
they like gathered a whole bunch of
mixed people and who knows like who they
were but just a bunch of people and so
they come into the desert and then the
the Israelites complained that they
don't have what they need they complain
they complain and then at some point
they complain too much it doesn't matter
for what idea is that
they complain too much and it says in
Scripture that it's the mixed multitude
that complained too much and you can
understand why that would happen because
if you're if you don't feel like this is
yours like if you don't feel you're part
of a group then you have it's easier to
complain because you're not covered by
the advantages of the group as much you
have less cover from the advantages so
it's easier for you to complain and it's
more it's normal that you'll be the one
who complains the longest who're
complains the most right and then in
Scripture what happens is God ends up
giving them what they're complain about
but he purges the edge of the camp and
so there's a / like a fire that burns
the edge of the camp okay
and that's some scary stuff man I told
you it's scary stuff now right after
that story like the chapter right after
that story there's a there's a balance
to it which is that Moses is married to
an Ethiopian witch like in let's say in
ancient thinking the Ethiopian was like
the ultimate foreigner right we don't
even know exactly who what actual people
they were referring to but it was like
referring to those people really that
live like on the edge of the world like
they're so far we don't know exactly
like they're very far and so he was
married to an Ethiopian woman and yeah
the idea is that she was dark like she
was dark-skinned you can see it in the
story that she was dark-skinned because
Moses his sister complains about the
fact that he's married to a foreigner
and Mary Trini Theo Pia and then because
of that she gets a disease which is that
she becomes too white her skin becomes
white like snow and because she becomes
white like snow she has to be excluded
from the group and she has to be cast
out of the of the camp because of that
so you can see the two problems like you
could call it an excess of mixture and
an excess of purity and those two things
happening you know one after the other
and almost being like like a call upon
each other because you can imagine that
after the mixed multitude problem the
reason why Miriam was complaining was
because what we just had this mixed
multitude problem now Moses is married
to a stranger so it's like it's one led
to the other and I would say that in
terms of what's going on right now we
need to be attentive to that especially
because things don't ever go just in one
direction they're gonna go in one
direction and then they're gonna snap
back like when Nazi
when Hitler was elected in Germany they
were on the verge of a communist
revolution it didn't just happen like a
gingered just happened when everything
was fine it's like you pull the pendulum
here it gets pulled in the other way and
it's hard to know which way is gonna win
like it could have been the other way
maybe the calm maybe Hitler could have
failed in his coup and then the
Communists could have taken over and and
and Germany could have ended up
you know sending people to the Gullah
like who knows but that's the problems
that one calls the other so I hope that
story is at least one example of those
two extremes and of appearing in the
story maybe great you had a question
that we could to piggyback on this one
yeah hi Jonathan thanks so much for
being here um my question was about um I
I don't know what your perception is but
my perception is that most people in
secular society don't really understand
secular society to be like broken up
watered-down Christian commitments and I
was just wondering if you think that
that sort of ignorance is like
exacerbating this sort of dangers that
these pseudo religious events pose for
us all yeah I totally think so I think
that that are they are the fact that we
despise history and we don't know about
history is really a call for all of this
to to keep getting worse because we
don't understand what's happening
everybody is moving from one side to the
other and nobody nobody knows what's
going on and so it's not so it ends up
having a being a caricature of
liturgical events a caricature of the
surgical feast a caricature of of like
the ancient celebrations that people
used to have but no one knows what's
happening and so the idea the idea is
that these patterns like this is why I
like for example like I'll call out
someone like Steven Pinker which is that
people are saying people are saying oh
look at these these you can see it
people some of the kind of atheist types
you look at these events and they're
like oh here again is a horrible
manifestation of our religious tendency
you know and so they decry it they're
like oh this is horrible that we
shouldn't this is just another example
of this kind of horrible stuff but the
problem is that it's not gonna go away
because you say that you know those
patterns are in you those patterns are
part of you they're like the example I
was used is you can complain that people
sleep because they're not productive but
they're still going to sleep you can say
if
you didn't sleep you would be more
productive but it doesn't matter it
still gonna happen the question is how
does it happen
does it happen half as early and
chaotically and we end up scapegoating
and sacrificing people and and like
beating people in the street or do we
have a ordered version which is what
religion offers which is what you know
which is what Christianity offered but
other religions offer that as well give
a place to funnel all those desires into
a kind of dance where instead of
actually killing each other or dancing
together thank you so much hey Erin
Rogerson you had a question I feel like
that question was just kind of answered
but you hi Jonathan
you mentioned sports have sort of a
healthy way of channeling tribalism in a
way and I was saying does religion in
some sense have the same effect and did
religion evolved to combat chaos and are
we returning to a pre religious time of
collapse and chaos in some ways well I
think religion what religion does is
more complicated than that
it's not about combating chaos it's
about integrating it all together and so
one of the things that I did I talked
about it's like Christianity for example
like Christianity is a religion where we
look at someone who is nailed to a cross
what the hell I mean it's not a just
about breaking order it's about
integrating the whole thing right it's
about integrating the entire thing death
to all the bad stuff to how do we
integrate the whole thing how do we
bring it all together and and you know
as much the order and the light as the
death and the darkness we have to be
able to kind of bring it all together or
else it's going to appear in in kind of
other ways now this is why this is why
the people who try to combat the chaos
you know let's say the Enlightenment
that's why they have a shadow that's why
they have a speaker Pinker says a
counter enlightenment it's just so
hilarious as if you can avoid it like as
if you could have just the Enlightenment
and not have the counter enlightenment
that's just not how it works that's not
our systems work and so the counter
enlightenment is just get stronger until
it explodes and then we have insanity
and we have crazy manifestations so so
yeah so I think it I think religion
offers more than just order it offers an
integration but it can be tribalistic to
like no doubt I don't want to pretend
that it's not and it can have tribal it
can become tribal and it can have
extremely it can be dangerous of course
you can but it's all about choosing do
you think which one is the most is the
least is the least going to destroy
everything thank you all right so we
read this on Stephens behalf how could
the absolution play out in a culture
that seems to believe that no one is
redeemable cancel culture what are the
alternatives I don't think I don't think
that it can work I don't think it's
gonna work I'm really look I hate to say
this but it's the only way for it to
work is scapegoating that's it that's
the way for it to work and and it seems
like we're already we're seeing a lot of
that but it can escalate
seriously escalated to the two minutes
of hate I mean that's that's the only
way out of it because the the only way
for the like the white liberal to get
out of their of their let's say guilt is
to find someone who's more guilty than
them and then turn around and scream at
them right there's no other way and so
that that will you know that will like
pileup if you watch the the Cultural
Revolution stuff like the Maoist stuff
you want to see where this goes it's
insane you'll have your people be
dragged
dragged out into public and publicly
humiliated publicly I mean I don't know
how far it can go in North America but
it's it's it's scary stuff and with the
alternative like the alternative is is
confession the alternative is
sacramentality the alternative is real
community you know that's that that's
the the that's the alternative like one
of the roles that let's say like it for
example I'm Orthodox like that's one of
the roles that confession plays a
confession is the way to to acquire
absolution but it involves accepting a
form of hierarchy so I do have almost at
the top of the hour can I sneak in one
more question yeah I'm totally fine I'm
having fun so it's fine
cool so yeah on the Orthodox piece see
Viking like came in two questions here
so one question is what do you think of
our buddies Jon's religion without a
religion or religion that's not a
religion to however you phrase it and
then the other one because I'm baptized
as Orthodox Christian and then you were
talking about um you know this this
reversal of guys like Gavin McInnes or
maybe 360 and kind of like Roush we were
talking about take apart as that was a
wild one he joined our our religion and
then and there's out early you know this
phenomenon the ortho bros you heard
these these yeah that's this rising up
um so yeah and so the what's the death
of jonah and here's your thoughts of
that and what is your thoughts into
orthodox christian in the role that it
could play and this is sort of like
ecstasy yeah well I I think I don't
obviously I don't agree I don't agree
with with the religion that's not a
religion I I think that I think that
there are certain aspects of humanity
which are inevitable and if you don't
take them into account because you don't
like them they're just gonna come back
it doesn't matter you can't avoid it you
can try but they're gonna come back and
so and so I understand
Ahn's fear like his fear of narrative
for example like I understand his fear
of narrative because because it can be
exclusionary you know because it's
identity because it does create identity
and he creates exclusion so I understand
his fear but there is no way around it
there's no way around it it's going to
come back and so so for example so like
John John talks about how he doesn't
want narrative but he does have a
narrative right he spent 30 hours in his
podcasts giving us the narrative of his
religion without a religion which is the
narrative of the breakdown of
Christianity and the the rise of the
Enlightenment and now reaching the end
and now like another post enlightenment
world so there is there is a narrative
and
there's something of the Tower of Babel
in what he's trying to do which is the
desire to create a tower that includes
everything that doesn't have that
doesn't have an outside and it just it's
just not possible
now the idea is to find a way to is to
find a way to have an outside or to have
a margin which has a role in which you
can encounter and that you can engage
with rather than just try to not have
one or not have a narrative or just be
the margin or just be it's like you need
to have the whole you need to have the
whole thing so I don't think I don't
think I don't think that it can work I
mean it can it work individually like to
help people out yeah I think so I think
so I mean I'm sure John has helped a lot
of people and I've seen a lot of people
really feel like he's helped them
through the meeting crisis and
everything and so so like I take
anything that helps people get out of it
is great I think it's wonderful so I
agree but I I think that I think that as
a let's say as a movement or as a kind
of social thing let's say this way
that's aid in evolutionary terms uh if
you have something which is too general
something which is specific is gonna
come like a needle it's gonna burst your
thing and that's it and that's the same
so so if you don't want to have a
narrative and you create this this kind
of amorphous like emergent thing without
a narrative then those that have a
narrative are gonna come in and they're
going to slash you to pieces
and they're gonna take over your
territory and it's just gonna happen
yeah so has for orthodoxy look and what
role get orthodoxy play
I think like for me I can just talk for
myself look guys I could just talked for
myself like I feel like I felt like I
feel like whis and Christianity lost the
plot at some point that they lost the
hire aspects the mystical aspects they
lost the the kind of system of
traditional of sacred language they lost
they kind of lost it and so as our own
system breaks down so now I talked about
this idea of the of the foreign or that
makes the mixed multitude or the thing
on the margin so you actually need that
stuff you need a little bit of it
especially when the system is exhausted
you actually have to go outside and get
some fuel from the outside and so my
sense is that orthodoxy is sufficiently
strange but not too strange in order to
to revivify some aspect of the West you
know and so I think that it has a lot to
offer and it has a lot a lot to offer
people who who want to be Catholic or
won't even want to remain Protestant or
whatever I think that it can have a lot
to offer because it has enough
strangeness that it doesn't feel like
the evil system that you want to fight
and it had it has like that it has the
the the appeal of the Orient you know
that kind of that kind of cliche of like
the golden turban wearing you know like
that imagery that you saw you know pop
up in romanticism like the east full of
treasures it has enough of that but it
also has enough connection that it's not
completely odd like it's not completely
off you're not just being an
idiosyncrasy in society you know that's
one of the things that I struggle with
kind of that I call the California
Buddhists is that it's so India Singh
Craddock to be a Buddhist in America
that I mean you can do it it's good it
might help you but it's it's your beak
you're still fragmenting thing it's
still participating in the fragmentation
by doing that so that's what I think
that's one of the things I think
orthodoxy can offer I don't that make
sense
mmm-hmm and it's a very very beautiful
religion if you look into it just
experience to go to church check it out
do you think it's on the rise too
exciting I noticed more people are
talking about it oh it seems like it's
hard because it's it's hard because
we're all in our bubble but for sure in
my perception I've had a lot of people
interested and you know interested in
the mysticism Christian just interested
in Christian mysticism reading the
Church Fathers I think that like I think
that some of the key Saints some of the
key think thoughts in orthodoxy offers
really good solutions to the problems
like I I really think st. Maximus the
Confessor offers one of the best
solutions to the problem of emergence of
the of the relationship between
consciousness and phenomena or the
relationship between meaning and you
know what kind of genre Vicki talks
about the problems of relevance
realization I think that st. Maximus
offers the the most integrated solution
both bottom-up and top-down approach at
the same time so from the top you have
name identity which kind of comes down
and acts as an authority but from the
bottom you also have the notion of the
coming together of the elements so it's
like the joining the fitting together in
love happening at the bottom and then
also the naming the head this image of
the top so it's not just top down but
it's also not just a kind of puzzling
emergence where it's like okay you use
that word but I don't know what you're
like how does it come together you need
those two to happen at the same time so
we're past that hour do you want to
sneak in one more question or should we
end here it's up to you guys I'm
attention yes so there's a good question
so we'll ask this one he wanted they
read it on his behalf as mojo and
Peterson and I'm curious to get your
download on that your thoughts on how
Jordans doing if you watched his recent
video with his daughter
so with points by Jordan Peterson in
yourself do you believe that the role of
symbols and myths could be recognized
and integrated in science as we know it
today the sign inside room or does the
boundaries of science have to be broken
to accommodate symbols and myths
so okay the way that that myth and and
religious imagery is going to be
integrated in the science is through the
science of of the human being it's
through looking back at the human being
and not not ignoring the experience of
consciousness right and as we look back
on consciousness as we try to use
caution is to look back on it then all
of a sudden I think that that's the way
that these that science can see the it
won't be scientific right but it can see
the the reason for these stories in
these patterns and they and these myths
and also understand that science itself
is always submitted to purpose there's
always a reason why you do things and
once you when you ask what that reason
is that's when you start to see these
stories come back in and so it's not in
the D it's not in the analysis it's not
in the thing but it's the reason why you
analyze which is subject to two
mythological storytelling right it give
you an example right so we developed the
atom bomb but we we just develop an atom
bomb we didn't just develop an atom bomb
we were in a war and we had these
enemies and there was a race who was
gonna get the atom bomb first and so
finally the Americans took some of the
enemy scientists brought them to
themselves and then created this atom
bomb so that they could defeat the last
remnants of the war and win the war
without that story there's no atom bomb
there is none why would you make an atom
bomb you'd have to be pretty insane to
make an atom bomb to be honest you need
that narrative in order to to justify
the research and so that it so I'm gave
you an extreme example but it's like
that for everything we always have a
reason to study things yeah that's
really really well put so I think we'll
end
here do you have any closing thoughts
for us at the Stoller
well thanks I I'm just happy to see
people trying to figure things out and
to ask the hard questions and to also be
willing to talk about things without
just letting ourselves be polarized try
to see both sides try to understand at
least the reason why the two sides
appear let's say in debates and so so I
appreciate it and I wish you all the
best if you give any thoughts on unstow
Susan actually because you know a lot of
people say they're like proto Christians
I'm not sure if you yeah how many
thoughts I do have a thought on my
thought on sources is that stoicism only
works if it's integrated into
Christianity for the same reason as what
I'm talking about in terms of the
religion without a religion I think
stoicism offers great practice great
advice great moral teaching but because
it never offered a narrative then I
think that it just it could win and
that's why I didn't win and I think that
once stoicism became integrated within
the Christian story then that's when it
actually took on its best fruits that's
when and that's why when people look at
early Christian saints and they say well
that's just a stoic I'm like yeah I
don't mind that I don't have a problem
with that because but it's a he's a
stoic because this is integrated into
also a cosmic story and a social story
and and and a communion a reason to
commune and that's what makes that's
what made the stoic that's what made
stoicism flower in the Christian age so
that's what I think of so this is right
cool so thank you so much my friend for
visiting the stoah we hope to have you
back
so I'll make a few announcements on
upcoming events we have like tons so
just go to the website to store that CA
but there's two tonight that I will
mention one is still the culture with
John Verve a key and a cure the dawn
that is at 7:00 p.m. Eastern Time so
John like when his first appearance at
the store he mentioned something like
that we got to steal the culture from
the people who have been abusing us for
so long and
it was like such a cool line I sentence
to Akira and then he made it like a
dance song out of it and so we're gonna
preview that at the stoah and john and
if you're gonna have a talk and we're
gonna have a talk together getting some
dialogo switch should be fun and then
our boy Tyson has an event tonight in
the inner wisdom Jim I think Tyson's
here so if you can unmute yourself Tyson
you can kind of like that sure thanks
Peter
thank you Jonathan yeah the event is
blowing with unknowingness that is at
8:30 Eastern Time it's a very playful
and musical experience where we practice
deepening our relationship with
uncertainty through freestyle rap and
spoken word and I'd love to see as many
of you as possible there it's a lot of
fun for me and I'm sure Jonathan is
going to join us on the Freestyle
tonight and give us the show some bars
hot bars okay so the stole is based off
a gift economy we view it as a gift for
all of us to use this time I need if
you're inspired to provide a gift to the
store you can go to the store that's
trash gift yeah so thank you so much
everyone thank you thanks again Jonathan